[Music]
the question i wanted to ask
just so i can sneak it in here if you
are
i guess mandated to take one of these uh
diversity trainer training or anti-bias
programs
say as an employee of somebody and
you're not comfortable doing that or
it's based on robin d'angelo's work
are there suggestions you have for for
those people
i threw up a couple of questions on my
instagram just
asking people if they had questions for
you and one of the main ones was
as a student or as a worker
how do you they use the term fight back
but what do you do if you're
like stuck in one of those anti-bias
things is there anything you can do
i really i really feel for people um
this is another area where i'm afraid i
have to say i don't
have a solution to that problem all i
have is sympathy with the problem
itself to be stuck in a scenario
where you are asked to hold your tongue
when you have eminently
reasonable things to say about the
underlying issue
but you know that the moment you open
your mouth
there is nothing you can say clear
enough or profound enough to prevent
you from being labeled um
you know a bigot or
an uncle tom or what have you
and the reputational cost you pay
is likely to outweigh you know the
benefits
of having you know of having diversity
of opinion in the room and it's so much
easier to just stay
silent that's one way in in which
the faulty information is so harmful
right is is once a false theory gets
instantiated and
a false treatment program if you
question it
your reputation is at stake but if you
don't question it
it can never be replaced by something
that might actually work
so a bad theory in in that sense
at least of this type is worse than no
theory at all because
standing up against the bad theory
appears to make you a bad person
yeah and ultimately it's a coordination
problem if there were enough people to
stand up to it at the same time
it wouldn't be a problem but there is a
this what what self-censorship
self-censorship
does is it makes every person in that
implicit bias
training who is having skeptical
thoughts in their mind
feel like they're the only person in the
room having such thoughts
yeah and they're not they're not right
right
that's why these kind of conversations
are important that's why what coleman's
doing is important too
is that if you talk about some con talk
about
topics even you remember um that black
box thing that happened on instagram
where everybody put a black box up
which i thought was ridiculous but i
woke up that morning and i looked at my
phone and everyone had this black box up
and i thought oh my god
now i have to put a black box up on
instagram and then i thought
that is a ridiculous thought to have
because you have to know that everyone
is noticing who doesn't put up the black
square
that's the most crucial part about the
black square yeah so i didn't end up
putting up a black box because it
i had that thought about no now i have
to and thought
like no i don't it's black box on
instagram it's not gonna make a
difference to anybody
um but it is hard when you get this like
anyway i didn't put up the black box and
then i had a whole bunch of people
message me who had
this black box saying oh i really didn't
want to but i did anyway
and at some point i mean it's different
i guess if you're going to lose your job
but
if you don't talk if you don't speak out
about some things that you think
are wrong you corrupt your soul well you
that and
isn't that how entire societies get
totally screwed up
like doesn't that can that potentially
screw up entire societies
yes it it certainly certainly has that
propensity across time